[Music]
[Music]
hello i'm daddy navage this is counting
the cost on al jazeera your weekly look
at the world of business and economics
this week
promises promises g7 leaders inflict
more economic costs on russia over the
war in ukraine we take a closer look at
some of the pledges they've made
also this week the import of russian
gold is banned by several nations what
might that mean for the market
as sri lanka's economic woes continue to
hurt millions we ask an expert how the
country can get back on track
[Music]
so leaders of the world's seven richest
nations met in germany this week to
discuss how best to forge ahead during
these uncertain economic times the group
of 7 or g7 includes canada france
germany italy japan the uk and the us
the war in ukraine energy global
investment and tech were some of the
topics high on the agenda and
multi-billion dollar pledges were made
to talk us through the numbers is
charlie robertson he's the global chief
economist at renaissance capital and the
author of the book the time traveling
economist he's joining us from london
welcome to al jazeera thanks so much for
speaking to us so mr robertson we heard
from germany's chancellor who's vowed to
keep the cost of running russia's war in
ukraine high for president putin and
also what we know is that russia is now
making just as much money from energy
exports as it was before the war so the
ban
hasn't really worked on russia the g7
are now looking at imposing price caps
on russian crude what impact do you
think that uh is going to have yeah this
is this has got a long history um if you
go back to uh looking at world war ii
and a few months after world war ii
began the west was was concerned about
commodity supplies supporting nazi
germany's efforts
and it even led to france and england
considering bombing russia's oil fields
in azerbaijan to stop them supplying oil
to hitler's germany who were good allies
of of the soviet union and the russians
at the time
and there was talk of of sending troops
across sweden um to support finland in
its battle against russia and uh and to
stop the iron ore mines in sweden
supplying uh nazi germany so this idea
of trying to interrupt commodities in
some way to to impact um war efforts on
the part of the aggressor has got a long
history
the question the big question here is
firstly can it work and there's a lot of
doubts about this price cap
as to whether it can work and the second
question is will the russians still
supply oil at the sort of 10 or 20
dollar a barrel price that's being
talked about i mean i think the russians
are looking for at least 60 oil when
over the last five to 10 years with opec
plus um so there is going to be a
question about the russians may say
we'll just cut back the oil supply if we
can't select the price um the world
price and the problem there
is that this really undermines biden's
chances for re-election in 2024. um
but u.s presidents who lose elections
who don't get re-elected it's always
because of a recession and that prospect
is very real so i think biden's trying
to save his job
and stop the russian war effort and
getting the support it's got but it's
very difficult to see how this is
how effective this can be right and i
mean we've seen the war in ukraine
sending energy prices soaring uh pretty
much globally how difficult is it for
members to sort of minimize the economic
damage around the world that's been
caused by these races
it's extremely difficult especially
given the scale of the fiscal deficits
that already uh were in were happening
because of covert um and and with
inflation this high offering any further
supports the economy is also problematic
so it's it's really tough um and and the
answer would be you wouldn't want to
start from here um 2014 we wrote that
germany needed to to cut its gas
dependency on russia um since 2014
gas dependency has risen
so it's it's not something that can be
sorted out in six months the g7 who also
pledged um or they set aside rather 29
and a half
billion dollars in assistance to ukraine
this year to help it close its financing
gap what might this look like
well i imagine it's going to be some
combination of
eu support us funding
imf getting involved
there'll be some debt forgiveness along
the way
um i'd suspect they're not counting the
military aid as that but that's also
extremely expensive um and 29.5 billion
isn't going to be enough um to support
ukraine i mean this is you know maybe
it's enough for this year but it's not
gonna be enough on a multi-year basis so
i think there's gonna be a long long
period of support
um and people are talking about
comparisons of the martial aid plan
and that went on for years um this is
the us supporting europe after world war
ii and and it's going to be a multi-year
effort with ukraine and uh
we also heard from the g7 that they want
to raise about 600 billion dollars uh
within the next five years that's for
global infrastructure what do you think
this means
well i think there's a number of
factors at play here first there's going
to be a bit of double counting i suspect
they're probably including the 300
billion euros of the eu global gateway
which is about supporting infrastructure
and supporting kind of renewable energy
i suspect it might include the 50
billion or so in the imf's
resilience trust the news kind of fund
that's been set up from the special
drawing rights and that's supposed to be
long-term financing to help countries
achieve more renewable energy choices
and i suspect the west is looking to
diversify the dependence on russia sorry
well russia and oil and gas china for
solar panels um i think the west would
like to see the infrastructure in place
the factories
outside of china that might produce the
cheap uh solar panels that the world
needs to to make this faster shift to
renewables you were saying just a moment
ago that the 29 29.5 billion pledged uh
for ukraine in your opinion it doesn't
go far enough what about the four and a
half billion dollars that has been
pledged to address food security issues
around the globe is that enough
well
uh it's it's it's a drop in the ocean um
compared to to the costs of food right
now the
where i think it might that may be
different is we put out a piece a month
ago saying that
um that actually global wheat
stocks are extremely high
and even if you assume that ukraine can
export nothing
this year or next year or indeed the
year after
you could still justify wheat prices
falling
and i think what we've seen in recent
weeks
is the market begin to realize that that
that ukraine's difficulties in grain are
not russia's problems i think russia's
export ban will will ease soon um russia
and india despite export bans have been
supplying wheat to egypt which is one of
the biggest consumers um i i suspect
that we can see food prices still come
down substantially even without the g7
doing so much so four and a half billion
doesn't go very far but i think the
global supply story for wheat is a much
much easier story for the world than
than the tight oil situation and what
about those rising inflation numbers
that we see globally i mean is inflation
here to stay and if so for how long
that's a million dollar billion trillion
dollar question and i don't have the
answer now i'm afraid um all all i think
i was reading this morning which is very
relevant to this is
that if inflation doesn't come down in
the second half of of next year and into
2023
i think the markets are going to be
deeply disappointed
and and they're going to have to get
get rid of the idea that the fed could
be cutting interest rates already
sometime next year um so it's it's
really important for the global economy
as well as for biden's re-election hopes
in 2024 um that that we do see inflation
come down over the next six to 12 months
all right charlie robertson we thank you
so much for speaking to us from london
thank you very much for having me
so as we just mentioned a spike in
energy prices bought about partly by the
war in ukraine has hit the cost of
living for millions and experts don't
see a drop anytime soon our
correspondent in berlin dominic kane
sent us this report on how some parents
living in europe's largest and strongest
economy are going hungry so their
children have something to eat
nicole gundlach prepares food for her
children they have been at school all
day and now back at home they're hungry
but if their needs are simple their
mother's task is not because putting
food on the table is becoming
increasingly more expensive so basically
right now with the the food prices going
so high
it's either spending two or three times
on the on the amount of food or buying
the the amount that i could afford and
then we have to eat less food so mainly
it means for me
buying less food and i'm the one who's
going hungry or not eating meals so that
the kids can get enough food and that
sort of stress has serious implications
for her and for her children it's very
hard on me because it causes a lot of
stress i'm always worrying sometimes i'm
not sleeping because it's like how are
we gonna eat tomorrow or what am i gonna
buy this week what am i feeding my kids
or even how is it gonna be in the next
months rising food prices have
implications for others too yozita
hattanto runs a vegan restaurant in
berlin's princelower bayark district the
lucky leak has won high acclaim from the
michelin guide with a reputation for
fresh and seasonal fare with a personal
touch but maintaining those high
standards with ever higher prices is
becoming increasingly difficult due to
it we have all the increasing prices for
like basic ingredients food and oil
everything
and of course it's a struggle
so
for example i had to remove my deep fry
because i couldn't get oil anymore just
so simple things and the dilemma does
not stop there
because the restaurant's overheads still
have to be paid every month meaning some
hard choices have to be made all my
suppliers increased their prices so when
i
checked my bills i was like what
yeah and of course i had to compensate
it in some
way and yeah the only way was to
increase my
the prices for the menus a little bit
these increasing prices are happening in
many sectors of business and industry
across germany at the political level
many say the war in ukraine is fueling
inflation combining a spike in energy
prices with a drop in the supply of food
stuffs
the chancellor says he knows it's
hurting his country
millions of citizens ask themselves
every day will my money be enough
will there be enough at the end of a
month these are very serious questions
questions which need a clear answer the
government has initiated extensive
relief measures for citizens and
businesses
one short-term measure the german
government has alighted on is cheaper
public transport throughout the summer
months for a flat rate of nine euros or
around nine and a half dollars each
month passengers can use local and
regional buses trains and trams to
travel anywhere inside germany but some
in the transport sector believe such
short-term schemes are not the answer to
spiraling prices
there were cuts too in the tax on fuel
but just a few weeks later the prices at
the pump are close to their pre-cut
level
such spiraling prices are common across
europe right now this was a protest by
pensioners in athens the common factor
rising prices and no rise in income as
patient is we are facing a lot of
serious problems every day due to
inflation at the supermarket at the gas
station we get our pensions and within
five to ten days the pension is gone
this can't go on
at eu summits and again at the recent g7
summit inflation has been discussed
and it's clear leaders are trying to say
we feel your pain but it's also the case
central bankers say there seems to be no
quick fix inflation will remain
undesirably elevated for some time
however
moderating energy costs the easing of
supply disruptions related to the
pandemic
and the normalization of monetary policy
are expected to lead to a decline in
inflation but some analysts are not so
sure and believe the markets tell their
own tale
almost all asset classes are in the red
at the moment and one can really feel
how people don't trust the central banks
anymore you get the impression that the
central banks have reacted way too late
the last time inflation was this high
was back in the early 1970s when this
wall still divided this city back then a
phrase was coined to describe the
combination of stagnant economy and
rising inflation stagflation
for now ministers say the threat of a
return to that era is distant
for now
dominic kane for counting the cost in
berlin
g7 leaders decided this week to ban
imports of russian gold sanctions
brought in since the war in ukraine
began have aimed to crush russia's
economy and have included bands or curbs
on oil and gas imports as well as
trading with russian banks and
individuals gold has always been seen as
a safe haven for investors and many turn
to the precious metal to protect their
hard-earned savings as record inflation
hit other investment vehicles global
demand rose by more than 30 percent on
the year in the first three months of
2022.
russia is the world's third largest
producer of gold after china and
australia and commands a 10 slice of the
world's output
gold is its second largest export after
energy and it's a significant source of
revenue for president putin the g7 hope
this latest move will isolate moscow
further from the global economy
last year gold made the kremlin around
19 billion dollars so how will this
latest move affect russia and the wider
market as a whole
to discuss all of this i'm joined now by
curiel kirilenko he's a senior analyst
with the cru group and specializes in
precious metals such as gold platinum
and palladium welcome to al jazeera
thanks so much for your time so how
significant is this ban on russian gold
given that gold is its second largest
export as you know after energy and gold
is an important asset for the central
bank which is already operating under
limited conditions
around 15 billion of dollars of worth
worth of dollars were exported to
london last year
so
obviously uh russia would not want
to lose a quarter
of uh
of the potential source for its uh
military budget
and it will try to
secure this money and
raise them from other sources when you
say other sources what do you mean by
that like whom
i mean from other markets okay not just
the london market which was effectively
already
closed for the russian gold
since uh since march so other markets
like who who could russia turn to
uh russia could turn to
asia
quite a lot of countries in this region
are not supporting sanctions at least
for now i'm i think
africa and latin america
are also not many countries during the
western sanctions
on this country although london is a big
international hub for trading there are
other markets where gold can be sold all
right so do you think this decision by
the g7 will affect the market as a whole
and if not why not
even if all the mines
producing gold at the moment
would be stopped there would still be
plenty of of metal in the background
stocks to pro to satisfy the market
needs so in a sense there is no physical
shortage of this metal and it can be
bought
but for example if
if the sanctions were applied to the
exports of palladium
that would be a different story because
palladium is in short supply the
background stocks are low and that would
have a
big impact on the on the market right
for this
talk us through why the public and
investors buy buy gold the commodity
well the public buys is it for two
reasons the first in the form of
jewelry it looks nice it feels nice
promotes your social status and the
second one you can also buy jewelry as a
form of wealth protection
so it's it's liquid it's easy to sell
later on and in such countries like
india for example it's a very popular
form of savings
and investors
buy gold because of its perceived safe
haven status because basically it holds
its value so for capital protection
uh gold has proved itself over centuries
that it's
probably one of the best assets to meet
these goals and for central banks why is
it that central banks buy gold i'm sure
uh the central banks buy gold
to diversify the
foreign exchange reserves
so basically because gold
doesn't hold any
uh counterparty risk so
there is no one who could
go back bankrupt for example this
promotes this the role of this metal
for central banks
and
in the periods of uh
increased market volatility and
political instability gold is also a
good source of liquidity and
as we noticed last year and the year
before some countries were actually
using their gold reserves to
raise money to fund their
boxing programs so is that where you
would put your spare money right now
then where would you put your spare
money seeing is it such a jittery uneasy
time
well i would probably
keep a certain portion of my savings in
gold
because it's still performed quite well
in
in different currencies this year not
probably in the us dollar it's only up
by about one percent
but in other currencies like for example
in
europe british pound gold has
delivered a robust performance over the
last six months
thank you so much
kirilenko we really appreciate your time
with us uh thank you for speaking to us
from london thanks very much for your
invitation a delegation from the
international monetary fund has been in
sri lanka for talks with its government
on how to help the nation move forward
sri lanka is looking for help as it goes
through its most intense debt and
economic crisis in decades a shortage of
foreign exchange has left it unable to
pay off loans and import food and
medicine plus petrol pumps have almost
run dry
rootio desai joins us now to discuss the
latest developments in sri lanka he's a
fund manager at asia frontier
investments over in hong kong welcome to
al jazeera thank you so much for your
time how much trouble is sri lanka
really in well actually the economic
trouble for sri lanka i i guess the
economic and political trouble of sri
lanka have been building up not just
over the last couple of months this is
the culmination of the pressures that
the country has been facing over the
last three to four years if you look at
what's been happening since 2018 at the
end of 2018 they had a political crisis
where prime ministers were trying to you
know there was
you know there was a attempt to change
the prime minister at that point in time
uh in 2019 you had the easter sunday
attacks which affected the tourism
sector the all-important tourism sector
and of course since 2020 you have the
pandemic which has really hurt the
tourism sector even further the last
maybe two years or more and i think
what's happened the last couple of
months with the war in ukraine which has
impacted both uh oil and also food
prices in which sri lanka obviously
imports that was probably the final uh i
would say near in the coffin for the
country given the pressures that they
were facing so they went into 2022 in a
very weak economic footing and the war
and you can has just really uh pushed
them into a corner at this point in time
right and there have been negotiations
going on with the imf what is the imf
going to
want to see
from sri lanka in terms of a change in
its policies
in terms of what imf wants to see
i guess
a lot of the economic measures
that sri lanka has taken over the last
couple of months has led to the start of
talks with the imf in terms of the sri
lanka has allowed the rupee to float
freely so the rupee has depreciated by
about 80 since march 2022 uh they raised
interest rates by 700 basis points in
april 2022 and also they've also
increased
fuel prices but of course these are just
initial measures a lot a lot more need
to be done in terms of uh having
sustainable financial outcome for the
country in terms of reducing the debt
levels and also their fiscal deficit
levels so the imf would really want to
see sustainable tax revenue measures on
on the on the revenue side and also the
government cutting down expenditures and
that's what they want to see over the
medium to long term not just over the
next six or 12 months right okay it's
also received pledges um of between 300
million to 600 million dollars from the
world bank and that's to buy medicine
because of course there are incredible
uh uh medicine shortages in the country
is this enough
well it's three you know such
it's less than a billion dollars so it's
it's okay to maybe meet your expenses
for the next couple of months of a
couple of quarters for specifically for
certain items like food and medicine but
this is not enough i mean they were
obviously i mean if you look at what the
government is saying they're talking
about getting about five or six billion
dollars over next couple of next next
year or so in terms of getting all their
obligations and their import
requirements and obviously they need
these short-term finances from world
bank and from other friendly countries
like india because of the fact that they
don't have any financial reserves to
import fuel or import medicine so yes
it's very important for the short term
but in the long run they need something
which is more sustainable right and in
terms of fuel we know that sri lanka is
sending government ministers to russia
to try and negotiate for fuel as the
pumps in the country run dry is this a
short-term fix or is it a long-term
solution do you think the supplier is
not confident in supplying fuel sri
lanka because they're not confident of
getting paid by the country
so clearly going to russia and going to
some other countries in the middle east
it's really a short-term solution to
overcome some of these difficulties that
they face but i think they obviously
like i said you know sustainable
long-term plan and over here they need
to build up their foreign exchange
reserves in the long term because you
can't uh sustain your country or economy
by you know buying oil short term over
the next couple of months only has to be
a more long-term plan over here right
and food security is
suffering as you know sri lanka is also
forced to import
rice the tea crop which is the nation's
top export devastated what changes do
you think need to be implemented so that
farmers in particular can survive and
the public can can start to get food
well such kind of policies is just uh
the example of the poor economic policy
making of the government over the last
couple of years and it's not just
agriculture the many other sectors which
have suffered because of i would say
short-sighted or a poor execution from
the sri lankan government in terms of
economic policies uh i guess obviously
once the situation improves once the imf
funds come in they can build up their
partial reserves bring back some
economic stability and then they can you
know have more rational plans for the
agricultural sector and therefore help
their
farmers and also you know build back
their food reserve as well okay thank
you so much richard josiah for speaking
to us from hong kong
thank you for having me
that's our show for this week get in
touch with us by tweeting me at
daddyunag and use the hashtag ajctc when
you do you can also drop us an email
countingthecosts.aljazera.net is our
address there's more for you online at
aljazeera.comctc
our website it'll take you straight to
our page which has individual reports
links and entire episodes for you to
catch up on
that's it for this edition of counting
the cost i'm daddy navigator from me and
the whole team thanks for joining us the
news on al jazeera is next